[موسيقى] أجنبية
أنا وزوجتي نحن أيضًا من كبار المعجبين
بالأواني الساخنة ونحن هنا
منذ سنوات عديدة ومنذ 10
سنوات مضت، لا يوجد مطعم جيد مثل مطعم Hot Pot،
هناك عدد قليل منها ولكنها
تقليدي جدًا، لذلك في ذلك الوقت كانت
لدينا فكرة عما إذا كان
الوقت مناسبًا يمكننا أن نجعل المطعم
مطعم هوت بوت كما نعتقد أن
نصف
القلب يشبه ببساطة غليان
الطعام مثل اللحوم والمأكولات البحرية
والخضروات أيًا كان ما تريد.  إذا كنت ترغب في ذلك، فالأمر صعب بعض الشيء
بالنسبة
للزيارة الأولى ولكن لا تقلق، فسنفعل ذلك
للزائر الأول وسنقوم
بترتيب أغراضنا للمساعدة في المفهوم الكامل،
ما نقوم به هنا هو أننا نقوم فقط باستيراد
المكونات و  التوابل القادمة من الصين
ولكن معظم اللحوم والمأكولات البحرية
والخضروات التي نشتريها من السوق المحلية
لدينا متابعة مع معظم
الزوار لأول مرة، حيث يشعرون
بالاهتمام الشديد بهذا النوع من
المفاهيم لأنه قبل الذهاب إلى أي مكان
آخر  المطعم ينتظرون فقط
تقديم الطبق وهنا
يمكنهم الانضمام كما قلت يمكنهم الانضمام إلى
مفهوم الطبخ ويمكنهم إعداد
الصلصة حسب ما يحبونه من الأطعمة
الأجنبية
[موسيقى]